as soon as the movie ends my my buddy's
like hey you apologize to my friend
right now and then and the guy's like no
and then my my buddy just reels back on
both he like grabs the chair and just
kicks the guy
starts bicycle kicking this guy like luk
[Laughter]
[Music]
K so do we know who Jonathan major is in
this room yes is he an actor we talked
about create as the antagonist and also
King the Conqueror formerly known as I
guess was it he and
Loki yeah as he has been fired from
Marvel now so he's not going to be Kang
no more Kang I think that's all done was
that your favorite character no I didn't
really get into it but that's kind of a
bummer though he's a [__] good act he
was supposed to be he was supposed to be
the big bad guy so he get fired because
he was found guilty of one count of
misdemeanor third degree assault one
count of second degree harassment he was
acquitted of of his girlfriend or of a
lady or something right uh yeah a
girlfriend I believe um he was acquitted
of two other counts of assault and
aggravated harassment in a split verdict
but Marvel dropped him because he was
found guilty of the misdemeanor third
degree assault and the second degree
harassment apparently within the 30
minutes of like the news breaking
exactly right 30 within 30 minutes of
the verdict he got dropped well they
want to separate themselves immediately
this might be a dumb question but I'm
going to ask it anyway a misdemeanor is
not that bad right a Mr demeanor is
worse yeah no it's not that bad right
theoretically no but on the scale of
charges in California you didn't even do
time for it that's what I mean so it's
pretty it's a ticket well I also think
it's one of those like a misdemeanor for
like any one of us joeo in here it's
like yeah it's not that bad but if
you're like like celebrity Hot Spot top
[__] or even just like if you're in the
middle of you're in the middle yeah
solid you know we're down we're like
down here so is there anything lower
than a misdemeanor well it's also what
the misdemeanor is about he was being up
his girlfriend right yeah there's an
altercation in 20 March 2023 with his
then girlfriend Grace Jabari in a For
Hire SUV in the middle of New York City
and uh we haven't heard much about this
by the way other than that happened and
then all of the sudden this court case
comes out and then we finally hear what
actually happened in the charges um so
what did he do like so he says he was
picking her up in New York right and he
says picking her up by the way was one
of the biggest mistakes of his life he
says I pick her up I put her back in the
car so when he says pick up he means
physically so there's video of this
right so they basically like argued in
the car and obviously you don't see that
but then there's a point where he tries
to leave the car right because they have
a chauffeur and then there's like Street
camera surveillance camera of this
footage where like she tries to get out
of the car and like grab him back in so
he picks her up physically and then puts
her back in the car or some [__] like
that was violent In Like A Gentle Way or
like [__] WWE like a crane game I
think it's just more of one of those
subjective like at the end of the day
this guy's a physically [__] capable
man this is like a white woman that's he
puts her in the car and he leaves yeah
and then and then but he doesn't just
leave it's like he continues leaving and
then she still goes after him so there's
like multiple like the camera continues
to change so they're running so he's
trying to diffuse the situation by
putting okay okay okay yeah and then
like like other bystanders because
there's like so many it's happening on a
New York like City street there's like
bystanders that are like watching this
thing happen he's a popular guy so
people are like now talking to her
they're like you know being like hey we
could take you home and all this extra
[__] hey look at that [__]
guy so so the altercation began in the
SUV after the then girlfriend saw a text
message from another woman on his phone
and uh she said that she tried to grab
the phone after seeing a message that
popped up and said I wish I was kissing
you so then she got hot right that's
probably just his agent we did a Wendy
Williams
audience yeah that's just agent speak
right manager speak it's Hollywood but
here's here's the thing though whatever
happened whatever happened in this
altercation tinsel tower tinsel tower
whatever happened in the altercation in
the car though she ends up having like a
dislocated middle finger or something
like that and scratches that's pre-exist
that's cuz she like
weak was it leather was it like like
coat scratches you know sometimes you
wear like a fabric that's like kind of
like SC like
elro right you know girls be bruising
easily yeah they just need glucosamine
or some [__] stiff collar bro cut you up
she probably doesn't eat any collagen
glucose mean deficiency yeah it wasn't
scratches if he has those buttons that
are unbuttoned and those things are like
deadly
dude huge damn so she said that he was
pulling her right hand behind her back
while holding the phone in her left
she's holding the phone he he's trying
to get the phone back and then she said
he he was twisting my arm and hand
trying to make me feel pain trying to
make me feel pain know what the
intention istim that's a funny way of
putting it he was trying to destroy my
feelings you you guys that's an Indian
burn you know probably just [__]
that's we all know that's a felony
that's not a misdemeanor dude a bab
that's a hate crime dude majors has
denied twisting your arm he said he's
confident he didn't cause those injuries
he said she went to grab the phone I
held the phone I pulled the phone back
she came on top of me squeezed my face
slapped me that's all I remember and
then he was trying to get out he was
getting out of the car he kept pushing
her back inside the car he get getting
out of the car he said the second the
biggest mistake of his life was picking
her up the second biggest mistake of his
life was trying to put her back in the
car D he just wishes that he's just
[__] so when he threw her back in
that's the assault part that well the
whole thing is part of the the assault
thing but the the altercation is kind of
what what got him into this so now he's
labeled as like a a woman beater it's
it's kind of what people have been
saying for a while yeah and do you think
guys who are like Jonathan Majors you
think they should just have like two
phones on them at all times yeah one for
the hoes and one for the shows no for
real though like if we're talking like
if we're going to keep it a buck like if
this dude is that's kind of an amateur
mistake at his level come on bro like
you got you can't have these ladies
doing this to you bro well also too like
I knew guy who was pretty pretty good
cheater he had codes he has his [__]
talking in codes that's what I'm saying
that's what you do what are some of the
codes dude I'm not kidding I should be
kissing you right now that means [__]
I swear to God on my life this actually
happened this guy we were at a movie
theater one time we're watching The
Social Network and the theater's packed
as [__] cuz everyone wants to see that
movie right and then this guy sits down
in my before I'm like I'm getting up I'm
getting popcorn or whatever guy sits
down on my seat and then this my buddy's
like hey my buddy's coming back he'll be
right back and this guy's like oh I
didn't see anybody in the seat so I'm
going to take the seat so so then my
buddy is like okay so then soon as I
find a seat as soon as the movie ends my
my buddy's like hey you apologize to my
friend right now and then and the guy's
like no and then my my buddy just reels
back on both he like grabs the chair and
just [__] kicks the guy starts
[__] kicking him like bicycle kick
the [__]
head bicycle kicking this guy like
[__] l k
right the noise so this guy's what a
funny attack yeah so he's bleed cuz yeah
my guy's like a [__] from
Massachusetts too he's like a [__]
[__] Patriots fan so yeah he's one of
those guys yeah you know you know those
guys yeah so that yeah this guy's all
bleeding and [__] and then um um he gets
up and then um he his wife by the way
she's also [__] [__] Patriots fan
so she's like that's right you
[__] piece of [__] and all
thisit so she's talking [__] so he spits
on her oh [__] right and then I block
the aisle so he can't get out so my my
buddy starts running towards the back of
the theater right okay so then um then
I'm with his wife and this wife's got
spit on her face she what the [__] and
stuff and um and my buddy calls her
right he's running doing whatever the
[__] he he calls her and he's like hey
uh code 361b and she's like what the
[__] [__] does that mean and he's like
he's he's like 361 blue and she's like
what the [__] is 361 blue I don't know
what the [__] that means right so so he
just keeps on Yelling this code and then
so he's pissed he's so pissed so by the
time we we Rond devu we Rond Vu right
cuz you can't just meet up the r v 361
cuz this guy used to do Target security
so he Target security a neutral location
bro so he's like we got a revu and
[__] we revu right back at my apartment
and he immediately unloads on her as
soon as she comes through the door he's
like what code 361b what the [__] does
that mean huh what the [__] does that
mean Kim and she's like I don't [__]
know I don't [__] know what that
means I told you that on the phone and
he's like that means like we need to
[__] you need to [__] get out here we
a r this and and she's just like I don't
remember this [__] I swear to God I
don't remember I don't work
security but he had his little codes for
like everything but he he's the only one
who knows the codes nobody gives a
[__] whoever work the security detail
knows it nobody cares this guy by the
way I think I've told you about him
before he's the guy who who showed me a
highlight reel set to like Limp Biscuit
of him doing like Target
takedowns at at Target security you see
guys with like
Vio Vio TVs walking towards the door and
then you just see him come out and
Tackle him
down
he's got like a super cut like a [__]
reel of this [__] like set to like Limp
Biscuit you know you meant Target the
department oh yeah there's a store dude
yeah dude it's so sick dude it was s to
like like what's that um that slip knot
song it's like um I'm
becoming
this oh my God I wonder if he looks at
uh looters today like this would have
never happened on my watch oh absolutely
I'm sure he does I haven't talked to him
in a while is he in Lost prevention
where he's in plain clothes and they
don't know it's him kind of thing or is
he just like a i he's wearing like a
black shirt and like khaki they used to
have like police looking uniforms yeah
they look like you know M cops I can't
believe your buddy kicked a guy in the
face out of he kept kicking him too dude
I want to know the details of code 361b
are and I'm going to teach Nina it's the
best man the teach Nina just tell her
about it one time in passing and then
expect her to know that forever for
always the best I wonder if it's still
considered assault if he hit her with a
limp
wrist if it's like a weak hit at that
point is it really an assault yeah what
if it's a spank is that an assault I
think yes I think that that I've been
guilty of assault in my life I tell you
that right now they locked me up what
was that part I think I saw something
about how she was like she got into his
apartment and was like knocked out on in
his closet did you see that oh yeah she
like that was like a different
altercation where she had like uh she
like passed out and he he called the
hospital or whatever and he was just
like yo like she's like knocked out at
my spot she's passed out and she has
like visible like choke marks on her
[__] like he reported it as like she
broke in and like fell asleep or some
[__] like put her to sleep I guess oh my
God yeah all right so he thinks he's
going to come back from this by the way
I'm not making fun of that but he thinks
he's going to come back from this and
that God has a plan for him and that he
says I'm a great man I do great things
for my culture and the world the woman
that supports me needs to be a great
woman there's an audio recording of this
that's what this is this is crazy she
like well one I think she's also kind of
crazy if she like pulled out her phone
and was like recording their
conversation you know what I mean I
think that's also well yeah I mean they
clearly sound like a tumultuous couple
but like in this audio it's really
[__] funny to hear this dude be like
I'm a great man a great man you know I'm
doing he really sounds like an actor
yeah and he's and he's like yeah it's
like he's monologuing yeah and then he
also says he's like he's like I was
trying to give an analogy um when they
were asking him in court to give context
to the conversation he was like I was
trying to give an analogy uh of what it
is I'm aspiring to be you know these
Great Men Martin President Obama trying
to give a reference point to that I was
attempting and did a terrible job at it
apparently I was attempting to motivate
to Enlighten to give
perspective and cuz he was basically
saying like why can't you be more like
ketta Scott King and [__] like that like
to his chick yeah it's [__] bananas
[__] bananas and like it sounds like
like he it's like a writer wrote this
[__] what does he mean Keta SC like
Martin tried to basically [__] man
handled her and she was cool with it or
what great men great men who have the
support of great women but he believes
he's a great man but she needs to be a
great woman she know ketta I see yeah
well
also MLK would cheat on ketta yeah so
maybe that's part out of it yeah that's
why can't you stand by me while I cheat
like Martin Luther King did well I to
these other [__] that's so funny PR
damn do you think he's going to come
back from it I I don't know bro it's one
of those weird things were like hearing
him on the interview like talk about
what happened I I feel bad for the guy
who do you feel did a worse domestic
violence cuz this is domestic violence
right who did worst domestic violence
Chris Brown and Rihanna Chris Brown for
sure he beat the [__] Jonathan Majors is
good bro he's he don't got no hits Chris
Brown is like iconic he doesn't have yo
yeah the difference is Chris Brown can
still do independent music and make it
and blast it out whereas movies is a
little bit different and Chris Brown's
trying to be a bad guy like he's trying
to be bad God he's so good at it is
Heath oh like that's his image yeah like
like who's his woman beating who's
joining who's becoming a pyu after
you're rich and famous that's weird
that's true he's a Gangster and a woman
beater yeah Chris Brown's a pyu huh now
he is he make it sound like that changes
your plans I was saying this of
entertainment in America I think he's
going to come back he'll be fine I think
I think Jonathan M I think he's going to
be fine like you said he's a really good
actor so I that's that is a big differ
if [__] what's her face Johnny de
chick oh yeah like Amber herd yeah Amber
herd she was still in [__] Aqua I
mean Mel Gibson kind of came back yeah
but they shot that like eight years
before though or he went to the
director's chair and like still produces
every all these [__] weird things so
like wealthy as [__] yeah Majors might
just [__] do stuff on the back end
yeah or he could Kevin space it and just
keep doing the character everywhere even
though nobody asked him have you seen
that [__] it's [__] great it's great
even though no one asked
it just keep being k out there dude just
kidding news careful boys is a brand
just kidding news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful boys they are very smart just
kidding news the number one podcast in
the
world
[Music]